j'ai vu que vous savez déjà évoqué la
possibilité d'un sixième je voulais
savoir s'il pouvait confirmer s'il y
aurait la présence de jay avec lui et
pourquoi il enregistre plus de disques
dernière question du sexe
moi j'ai fait cette première question je
suis que la fox qui voudraient entendre
ce que je vais dire je veux faire un
choix je pense aussi que quelqu'un qui
est en train de téléphoner à fox pour
préparer ce prochain film
en fait on a tous décidé dans ce film a
commencé à tourner on a vraiment il
fallait que nous avons notre histoire
dumas cgt qu'on invente fallait qu'on
invente fille parce qu'il devait partir
maintenant tout inventé et on a continué
à inventer c'est quoi cette partie de la
question
chaque rapport avec la musique souvenirs
sa lenteur fait un album depuis si
longtemps
jason day break j'ai vraiment choisi de
prendre une petite pause plus de tourner
avec ma maman mais je t'ai je vous
retrouve travailler avec d'autres si le
temps en temps me demande d'où semble
être avec les autres nations
j'écoutais beaucoup quand j'étais enfant
c'est ce que je fais en ce moment mais
je ne vous ai pas et je préfère rester à
la maison que d'être à l'externalisation
qu'un micro